[Musique]
tiens où sommes nous mort aux états unis
je reconnais la statue de la liberté
[Musique]
de quoi discuter mais ces trois là ils
veulent construire des immeubles mais il
n'y a plus de place à non tout on n'est
pas d'accord
credo schiano plusieurs années qu'ils
ont une étrange idée
ils veulent prolonger la terre en
comblant la mer et de cette façon ils
ont de la place pour construire de
nouveaux immeubles
[Musique]
et voilà les immeubles se construisent
et qu'est ce qui leur prend en compte à
hauteur et en face de l'autre côté de
l'océan
que se passe-t-il mais ils font pareil
[Musique]
mais réfléchissez mais l'océan va
disparaître oui évidemment on peut
traverser à pied
regardez l'augmentent voilà ce que c'est
que de vouloir prendre la place des
océans
la nature se défend
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà l'idée de watou bateau rapprocher
le soleil de la terre pour faire
évaporer l'eau regardez bien
[Musique]
bon là il faut que la mère reprenne sa
place
[Musique]
ben voilà c'est bien mieux comme ça
allez bonne traversée et soyez
raisonnables respecter la nature
au revoir aux toitures merci
nous
pour
oui
oh